[Musik]
ich fühle mich zum ersten mal klein in
meiner küche
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ja heute gibt es mein erstes
weihnachts rezept gemeinsam mit robin
verlegung auch bekannt als robben ja
durch den weiten weg hierher gereist
ihrer stuttgarter stuttgart nach
waghäusel auf dem weg nach frankfurt
frankfurt oder sind auf tour mit unserem
podcast und da gibt es einen stopp der
war ganz wichtig ja wir sind ja auch
direkt zwischen stuttgart und frankfurt
man sagt ja auch frankfurt bei waghäusel
und stuttgart bei waghäusel
deswegen wusste er da komm ich vorbei ja
wir haben uns schon kennengelernt war es
in paris oder in berlin
das weiß ich nicht ich glaube ich glaube
wir haben uns vorher schon mal meine
schwimmerische ist eine londoner ist
eigentlich sehen wir uns immer nur in
die metropolen der welt war der neue
london paris ganz genau
ja perfekt das wird so das wird als
zitat irgendwo 1000 betrieben ja und
heute haben wir gedacht backen wir
zusammen und wir machen noch ein podcast
ich muss dazu sagen das ist mein erster
öffentlicher podcast ich hatte mal einen
gemacht an der hochschule damals über
wasser also was ist wasser zu trinken
diese war so wir haben im jahr so
entstehen
wir haben sogar ein lied das wasser mit
sprudel oder ohne
und dann haben wir eben dass man viel
trinken muss im podcast gemacht für
kinder aber tolle dinge seien fragen
wieso livestream oder ja ist doch ganz
egal ungesüßter tee so in etwa war der
aber ich habe ihn nicht gesungen
deswegen woche gut ja und das machen wir
heute und wo wird ich muss echt ganz
blöd fragen wo läuft der podcast über
alles packt das gibt der heißt game of
thrones und medienpädagogik also über
als podcast gibt 321 soundcloud jede
andere prozesse und podcast sind einfach
ist quasi wie ohne bild ja ok radio gut
und das ist für mich wirklich komplettes
neuland navi radios stimmt nur ohne
nervige moderatoren also ohne effekte
schon perfekt okay das heißt wir machen
gleich nach unserem podcast über medien
genau also dass crusoe als als mutter
vielleicht weitergeben kann
zudem weil du bist ein super präsident
natürlich in allen medien bis auf
podcasts bisher und hass kinder die
natürlich auch das alles mitbekommen und
er hatte komponente wie du damit umgeht
ist im vergleich zu anderen eltern von
ihnen nicht dieses medien müssen haben
was du hast ja wie wird eigentlich gerne
von euch wissen also von meinen
zuschauern hört er als podcast kann man
den abstimmungs funktion rein machen die
anderen geht ja es stimmt doch mal ab
und dann kann man mal gucken und ich
habe mir gedacht wenn du schon da bist
backteam er auch war sehr gerne die
weihnachtszeit kommt ich wollte
eigentlich schon schmecken aber kam
leider viel dazwischen kindergeburtstag
und alles und jetzt machen wir linse
schnitten linzertorte kennst du
bestätigen dass auch in mannheim geboren
ich komme aus der gegend also ja und
jetzt mach mal ins abschnitten das sind
einfach keine kekse und die eignen sich
hervorragend für die weihnachtszeit
und dafür brauchen wir einfach nur 250
gramm mehl einen halben teelöffel
backpulver 250 gramm kalte butter 200
gramm haselnüsse 150 gramm zucker eine
prise salz nelken und zimt und 2 eigelbe
gut viel werkzeug brauchen wir nicht ich
würde sagen möchtest du die hasen
schreiben sehr gerne habe ich noch nie
gemacht
dem musiker agenturen die musst du
eigentlich hätten jetzt einfach wieder
irgendwas anstellen soll hier den deckel
weg
reinstetten und dann kurbeln und nicht
drücken sondern wirklich besser arbeiten
als robert hat schon geschafft
juni das in den becken zu füllen und
dann klingen natürlich nächsten kurve
hier musst du gar nicht drücken sondern
wirklich geht
ich kann hier einfach die restlichen
zutaten in die schüssel geben einfach
erst mal alle trockenen und hier könnt
ihr auch dinkelmehl benutzen
ihr könnt laktosefreie mutter benutzen
vegane butter benutzen also das rezept
ist echt gut ab wandelbar
das nicht direkt zur polizei
schon mal eines ellis welt fitness nein
gesagt ja ich habe gedacht ich baut ist
einfach mit den küchengeräten aufwachse
privat auch oder ist es mehr so wie ich
kochen das ich sehr gerne backen eher
weniger das habe aber als als
jugendlicher immer sehr gern gebacken
ich habe super gerne anis kriegste
gemacht und ich habe mir in amerika
besonders schüleraustausch und wollte
meine gastfamilie da auch quasi wenn du
hast du willst ich bin jetzt hier gast
und haben jetzt ein deutsches rezept
hiermit und ich meine alles kekse und
habe ich denen das gebacken natürlich
gefragt was hast du denn da gebacken
habe ich halt versucht an wie es sie auf
englisch auszusprechen wirst eines
cookies
das war ein leichtes missverständnis
kann man das aus strand ja also ich hab
ja nichts aus weil sie geschmacklich
geschmacklich fand sich sehr geehrt
die assoziation noch nicht so okay weil
in der türkei ist wo da hat der [ __ ] von
der erfahrung gemacht
wir essen hegt total gern lebkuchen
gewürze und da ist ja alles mit pfeffer
und ingwer und in der türkei essen
dieses nicht weil sie sagen es schmeckt
wie medizin also die mühlen absolut
diesen geschmack nicht mit den
verschiedenen gewürzen zimt ist gut aber
so alles andere ist auch gleich fertig
alles in eine rührschüssel und bisschen
verrühren verkneten
das gebe ich dir kann man nichts falsch
machen
[Musik]
und jetzt nimmt sie einfach den teig und
bei bedarf können wir noch mal kurz
durchkneten aber der ist schon wunderbar
verrührt perfekt
den gebe ich jetzt hier auf einem teller
zurück in flach so kühl doch schneller
durch dann abdecken und für eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank eine perfekte
halbe stunde für den podcast eick ist
kalt aber etwas weich ist aber nicht
schlimm denn wir kriegen den so trotzdem
ausgerollt möchtest du dich immer auf
rollen sehr gerne da käme blamiere mich
gerne aus warte ich mach's dir einfach
wie ich mache dir so abstandsradar in
gleichmäßig wollte vorbereiten sagt
vergessen das haben schon plätzchen
gebacken die also dieses jahr noch nicht
aber in meinem leben von der menge dann
hat man oft das problem dass die dann
unterschiedlich dick werden mit die
einen verbrennung schon die anderen
nicht durch und deswegen immer ganz
praktisch wenn sie gleichmäßig sind
finde ich faszinierend bei dir wie man
solche tun fasst die ich nirgendwo
anders je gesehen habe und dann immer
denke die entwicklung wird dann halt
eine familie also wirklich sehr weicher
teig ist und noch so feucht brauche ein
bisschen mehl oder etwas mehr mühe als
normalerweise
normalerweise wenn du plötzlich fast
kein mehl und wirklich ganz wenig ok
dann rollen mal aus das sind jetzt so
ungefähr zwei drittel wird diese
expertenmeinung fange ich von hier der
vermieterin mitte mit am ende soll ein
rechteck werden
gibt gibt es gibt es dieses schöne
schablone von dir auch in den rat bitte
brauchen etwas weniger druck also am
anfang so damit das okay praktisch die
möglichkeit hast sogar zu reagieren
das haben wir jetzt mal raus erst am
anfang nicht zu viel drücken damit da
eben nicht gequetscht sondern gerollt
wird aber ist immer cool wenn ich dann
die gäste habt dann sehe ich nämlich wo
vielleicht fehlerquellen liegen können
will und dann versuche ich beim nächsten
mal besser zu erklären dass man nehme
den teig etwas mehl darüber und mit
leichtem druck so etwas wieder von unten
wenn jetzt damit er eben unten auch
nicht lebt und wenn du genau beide hände
und dann immer mal wieder drehen und
wenn den rund haben willst musst du ihn
öfter drehen und wenn du ihn eckig haben
willst was weniger im cockpit schon
[Musik]
und hier kannst du jetzt praktisch gar
nicht zu dünn ausrollen denn der aus
holz starb der stopp da einfach da kann
ich ja einig also von mir ist das jetzt
schon perfekt perfekt perfekt weil ich
wurde auch schon was einmal jetzt hier
ein backblech mit einer backform tabak
rahmen
jetzt sehen wir dass hierüber und zwar
mit dem und manchmal löst sich von unten
nicht dann gehst du einfach so mit einer
palette der unterschied praktisch das
mehl sein so und dann gibt's nicht mehr
jetzt ist es nicht obwohl jetzt aber das
meiste schon erledigt aber du darfst den
anderen raus rollen joghurt erst noch
mehr
denn was ist typisch bei einer linse
linzertorte das dann nach oben ja das
geht
ich gucke jetzt einfach mal wie groß wie
das hier gemacht haben war ich geb dir
noch den rest von hier
das heißt wir haben jetzt hier 30 mal
schaffe ich 30 0 25 das schaffe ich guck
mal ich mach jetzt hier so 30 mal 25 und
hier die kleine lücken füllen war
einfach noch so und den rest nehmen wir
auch für skater
ich versuche halt echt immer alle
rezepte so genau wie möglich anzugehen
genau maß genaue maße nicht 20 mal 30
ist gerne wird es zu dünn zu dick und
dann weiß man schon ganz liegt und das
gebe ich dir auch noch dran gewöhnen und
wie gesagt noch ein bisschen mehr drauf
und dann schaffst du das mit dem
ausrollen
wir haben jetzt gerade ein podcast und
zwar echt super interessant war für mich
eine ganz neue erfahrung die wir im
prinzip einfach ein lockeres gespräch
war ein wie jetzt nur oder backen genau
was dann entspannter für dich oder ja
weil ich mich nicht übernehmen und kein
problem ist nämlich erwartet man dass
noch zu wenig
nein nur etwas zu wenig mehr glück hier
so ein bisschen so und jetzt noch ein
bisschen noch eins drauf
und dann nicht vergessen so bisschen
drehen so ganz hatte heute nicht so viel
und jetzt wieder unten lösen oder eben
drehen ja so ja da man jetzt daraus ja
noch ein bisschen weil in der mitte ich
sehe noch da ist noch ein bisschen
dicker das siehst du dass ich das
geschulte auge
das ding ist wenn da einfach mehr
drunter ist dann flutscht ist besser auf
der matte kokett wirkt deswegen ging es
eben nicht jetzt kannst du noch einmal
drüber unter noch perfekt
das ist super aber ich habe jetzt auch
noch mal die räder getauscht denn wir
machen 3 mm fürs gitter
sonst wird es zu viel also zu dick und
wahrscheinlich reicht ja deswegen her
aber nochmal 3 es ist echt schwierig für
mich jedes jahr neue plätzchen rezepte
zu machen weil es einfach schon viele
gute wird und ich meine top marques
oftmals ist man habe doch immer die
gleichen
ja das ist richtig
als only sunnys kekse mag ich sehr gerne
deutschen nicht englischen genau
vanillekipferl bin ich kurz was fremd er
sich tatsächlich noch nicht gemacht dem
muss ich also die waren doch schon aber
noch nicht auf dem kanal ich finde das
schon so ein klasse gesagt der klasse
gehören soll ich meine koffer packen
ja ja dann also eine skizze schon mal
gemacht nähen und der murat mag die auch
gerne
dann wird es zeit angst kekse schreibt
man welche plätzchen würdet ihr euch
noch wünschen was dem beide
lieblingsplätze was sind denn den
lieblingsplätzchen deine maus ich kann
es nicht auf posten da wird es nicht mal
schwindlig das muss der papa machen gibt
mal dem papa was sind deine
lieblingsplätzchen
die zunge verschluckt da kaum einmal
noch drüber doppel muss und meine
lieblingsplätze ja auch man den gipfel
und ich habe so schoko mandl kekse
danach so einem teig und tust du so oft
blech klecksen und fertig gebacken
wir sehen immer gut aus habe ich hier
ein gewähltes rat ist nicht spitz also
kann man sich nicht schneiden deswegen
trifft auch auf der seele konnte
schneiden und jetzt machen wir einfach
dieses gitter ich versuche 11 druck
gleichmäßig wie möglich als sonsten
könnt ihr euch natürlich in den jahre zu
hilfe nehmen so ein bisschen dran halten
mag so weitermachen
es wird auf jeden fall schiefer als
verlieren du schaffst das
er ist linkshänder ja ich bin orcas wenn
es schief ist liegt es daran dass ich
nicht gut auf fries ja und ich kann
schon mal in der zwischenzeit den teig
mit marmelade bestreichen
das heißt wichtigste du kommst ja
ursprünglich auch aus unserer gegner und
bei uns hier ist man linzer torte mit
pflaumenmus aber in österreich mit
marmelade johannisberg mit roten glaube
ich brot meistens mit fast wie eine
regierung und linzertorte für dich mit
+3 musste was machen wir jetzt nehmen
wir jetzt hier die regel marmelade
schwarze johannisbeere oder fahren muss
ich würde sagen wir probieren das mal
über dem das andere kennen ja eben ja so
waren wir dass das ist gut wenn ihr mit
johannisbeere und hab ich jetzt keine
selbst gemacht hat indem wir jetzt aus
dem glas schwarze johannisbeere
zuerst wollte ich mich ganz bis zum rand
streichen eben das ist so ach warum
nicht gestreichelt bis zur wand die
kriegs später wahrscheinlich gut wieder
weg wie viel marmelade ist so viel mehr
beladen
ja das wird noch ein bisschen mehr so
oft die größe was ich bei dir so mag ist
dass die monat
also durch das backen eine assistenz
gewinnt und dann ist es einfach ja und
an manchen stellen außen wird die so
karamellisieren
ach weißt du oftmals denke ich mir warum
noch neue kuchenrezepte machen es gibt
so viele mega klassiker die ich einfach
immer wieder gern esse aber dann fällt
mir doch wieder was neues ein und ich
wollte auch mal wieder was neues habe es
eine linse ist schon gut
ich glaube so ist gut ich will man sagen
sozusagen die millimeter dick das waren
jetzt fast erschlagen
300 das waren 200 200 gramm das klingt
gut
so bitter ja ich war noch nicht so weit
sondern wir durchdenken das rezept aber
ich bin jetzt einfach so machen wann
immer wir nehmen hier den rahmen
und nehmen das ballett oder klebt ein
bisschen aber es geht ja palette oder
langes messer und dann würde ich sie
einfach jetzt diagonal drauflegen aber
durch die marmelade lässt sich schön
schreiben ja und die anderen legen wir
so nahe dran und wenn es reicht machen
angeht da draußen wenn ich lassen war so
etwas ins solange es dabei bleibt und
wenn es zu kurz ist der name aus dran
okay vom abstand herrsche und so
bisschen platz lassen
ich lass' ich mal dahin das wird jetzt
wahrscheinlich zu lange geführt als er
plötzlich jahr das ist ja mal die
kräftig habe automatische kürzungen für
alles absicht ja jetzt nicht mehr so
wirklich und
man kann man ein bisschen kleben
[Musik]
zufrieden ich bin zufrieden also wurde
dafür dass es das erste mal das ich hier
gemacht habe bei einem länder gitter
perfekt bin ich ja sogar der kamera sind
auch das gut er ist unsere arbeit ist
getan
im winter backofen erledigt den rest ab
in den ofen
so stehen auch mal unters blech in der
hand halten das machst du sonst ja das
ist ja richtig aufwendig hier also ich
balance erst dann auf eine hand von
unten genau mache ganz elegant auf
lächelt dabei noch in die kamera und
schiebe es dann unten mal ein zweitauto
ja in die mitte genau bevor sich nicht
verbrennen und jetzt gleich noch kurz
anheben das praktisch so elegant
schließen und da wieder eine pirouette
perfekt
[Gelächter]
fertig gebacken c70 sagt sehr gut aus
frage dich aber milde hat genau die
richtige konsistenz die sie haben ist
für so eine torte und eine schöne farbe
ja hier hatten wir übrigens auch kleine
kugeln gemacht aus den drei größten und
jetzt lösen wir das thema raus der harte
klebt jetzt am rand ein bisschen weil
die marmelade jetzt etwas karamellisiert
ist aber dafür haben wir keine rand
stück von doch mal laden bis zum rand
bist du berlin sagte er so an stücken
erster oder marmelade ja umso besser
also ja ja
22 und das ist nicht so praktisch so
normale kekse ohne fehl und tadel
einsatzmittel und wie schneiden jetzt
noch einen streifen zu streifen oder
rauten und ich denke mal da kommt sie
wieder die palette von pecik unsere
gitter richtig prozess sieht sehr gut
aus
so hat es doch nur schöne frau eine gute
länge so für so einen snack yanar reicht
der morath hat jetzt natürlich ganz
schwäbisch das ganz klein geschnitten
ok dann los
so weit war ja dass man eigentlich
müssen ja so plätzchen und gebäck immer
durchziehen aber ich es ist frisch
gebackene mama das klebt man den zehn
höfen schneidezähnen ich hätte auch
nicht mehr reden tut mir leid das ist
super lecker hören dieser boden haben
wieder knusprigen schicht oben durch das
gitter sondern auch sehr gute
entscheiden was wärst du da gemacht
haben ja und dann die marmelade
dazwischen hier an der seite da ist so
ein stück ist sie aber das sehen kann
hier so schön so muss das sein so nach
konsistenz musste sogar milliarde haben
hinterher es habe keine marmelade
bisschen wieso frucht leder kennst und
leder diese stroke getrocknete aber ich
finde um jetzt ganz ehrlich zu sein
hätte das ganze glasmann rat darauf
müssen ich glaube auch daran hat das war
auf jeden fall dicker sein ja und ja ich
enders auch im rezept 300 gramm
das war einfach die schwäbische seite in
mir das war ich dachte es wäre zu viel
aber nein das ganze klappt sehr gut aber
ansonsten perfekt wenn es jetzt halt
noch durchzieht wird es noch weicher und
zart aber ich mag es noch frisch
knusprig auch ganz wären ja echt cool
und jetzt haben wir praktisch unser
rezept fertig unser podcast ist fertig
meine allererste ich bin sehr stolz
drauf
ja danke dass ich hier dabei sein luft
und da ist ja voll cool wollte die neue
erfahrung für mich und ich bin jetzt mal
gespannt wie meine zuschauer auf den
podcast reagieren und den findet man
dann wohl auf spotify oder itunes oder
einer sap sei einfach thema frauen
suchen
in der video beschreibung für alle
podcast anfänger wie mich nicht ich
setze die links in die video
beschreibung wie hat es war wirklich
schön falls man mit der lust es zu
backen oder kochen wenn ich in stuttgart
frankfurt waghäusel bin jederzeit
jederzeit vorbeischauen
also viel spaß danach machen das rezept
gibt es auch sallys - blog.de und den
podcast hier unten in der video
beschreibung bis dann tschüss war gut
ich es nicht vor der kamera
ich glaube immer murat essen und wenn er
dann mit vollem mund spricht es egal so
richtige trikot
da kommen da schon kaum spricht man
reinkommt kommt probier mal
natürlich machte plätzchen winzer
schnitten wir machen nur marmelade
reines nächste mal habt ihr auch
zuckerreduzierte und nicht weil ich
nicht so süß werden mit riesel marmelade
johannes dennis barth video die probleme
jetzt robbins robbins weltverband
daraufhin stuck und korpulent bis gleich
[Musik]